hey Steve my new hat moneymaker is doing
great turns out a lot of people want to
trade stocks from their phones but now
I've collected all these account numbers
and credit card numbers I'm pretty
worried about protecting all that
sensitive information so I can maintain
the trust of everyone using my app
sounds like you need some additional
security what if one of your employees
has had to go rogue and start their own
competition oh no I definitely need to
minimize any data exfiltration either
from a disgruntled employee or any
attacker great how do you control data
access today well I've got some
sensitive data but it's stored so that
many projects have access to it I'm
really worried about unauthorized
copying going on can you help absolutely
I'll show you how a VPC service controls
perimeter can make you more secure great
all right we've got two projects one
that has sensitive data and one that is
attempting to exfiltrate data each
project has its own storage bucket the
sensitive storage bucket is locked down
and is only accessible to a select few
service accounts for this example we
will use this service account Oh No an
attacker gain access to our service
account and to the sensitive data
they've added the compromised service
account to an unauthorized project and
created a bucket to excellent rate data
using the cloud storage API let's take a
look here I'm acting as the malicious
actor I copy sensitive data account
numbers from the customer account data
bucket to the excel traded customer data
bucket using the compromised service
account the malicious actor copies the
data to their own bucket and can now
allow access from it outside the company
that's bad right
how do we protect against that we'll
create a perimeter with VPC service
controls this lets you lock down GCP
services similar to how firewalls
protect your servers from the console
we'll go to VP c service controls and
select our organization this perimeter
controls which projects can call on the
GC PAP is specifically allowing only the
ones you choose I give it a name in this
case super x'l tration protection then
choose the project I want to protect
finally I'm going to choose to restrict
the storage API
any storage API call coming from outside
that perimeter will fail now only
storage API calls from inside this
project will be allowed success our data
is safe or at least safer as you can see
you can use bpc service controls to lock
down your projects and protect sensitive
data that's great I'll go set that up
today and it keeps me safe from
attackers inside or outside my company
this is just one of the many tools that
Google cloud provides to make sure your
public cloud workloads stay as private
as you need subscribe below to get more
content like this and comment with
questions or feedback so we know what
you want to hear our next time thank you
for joining us
[Music]